thank you very much and good afternoon
and thank you Estonia for Hana for
hosting us today it was important to
come here because while we're often
focused on Ukraine we shouldn't forget
that countries like the countries in the
baltics are right on the front line of
Russia who may or may not seek to put
pressure on those neighbors and as you
stand here in this Hangar you have
Danish tanks you have french military
serving here you have British and
Estonian uh doing the other part of the
job which is reassurance on the borders
and boundaries of NATO that we are
determined to defend ourselves as well
as support Ukraine
when President Putin started the
Invasion on the 24th of February he made
a number of assumptions the first one
being that ukrainians would not fight
the second one being that his Superior
military as he thought about it would
quickly Crush any resistance and by now
in fact within three weeks he would be
pretty much in control of Ukraine and
finally he banked on the fact that he
thought the International Community was
fickle that it wouldn't stick together
that we wouldn't see it through and
indeed by now we'd have all got bored
and been bullied by high energy prices
well none of those have turned out to be
true
2023 is about demonstrating to Putin
that that last point the point that the
International Community isn't uh
fractured that the International
Community is more than ever determined
to stand by Ukraine to see it through
you know we are here today and we'll be
here tomorrow in Ramstein in the United
States hosted a Ramstein conference with
many more of our both NATO Partners but
also other non-nato nations to make it
very clear to President Putin that we
will continue to donate continue to
train and continue to stand by Ukraine
because of President Putin is banking on
us getting bored this year he's wrong we
will plan for this year and next year
and the year after and Beyond it as the
prime minister of Finland I think
referenced yesterday this is for the
Long Haul we're in it for the long haul
but in 2023 it's time to turn the
momentum that the ukrainians have
achieved in pushing back Russia into
gains and making sure that Russia
understands that the purpose now is to
push them back out of Ukraine and to
restore Ukraine's sovereignty which is
their right under international law it's
their right in being able to defend
themselves and it's also in their right
because it is the same rights we all
enjoy as free members of Europe to hold
up to Human Rights and international
standards the United Kingdom has
unlocked a number of packages in the
last year we're going further beginning
of this we announced to Parliament that
we will send a squadron of Challenger
two main battle tanks to Ukraine we will
send at least three batteries of as90
155 long range Deep Fire artillery we
will send a number of armored vehicles
including the I think it's the Bulldog
which is a variant of the old 432 armor
personnel carrier thousands of rounds of
ammunition and today I can say we're
also going to send another 600 Brimstone
missiles into Theater which will be
incredibly important in helping Ukraine
dominate the battlefield we'll be
working tomorrow with obviously the
United States and others to make sure
that this package is put into Ukraine in
the right way that it enables Ukraine
and underlying all of that is the
enduring training package that we are
all engaged in around not only Europe
but also in the in United Kingdom we've
just started as of this week another a
round of training basic training
ukrainians Britain's aim is to train at
least 20 000 there may be more training
uh and we are helped by that from
everyone from uh Lithuania Denmark
Sweden Finland uh Australia New Zealand
uh I'm just trying to run Estonia uh
here and uh
with the Dutch as well so we've got a
significant number of nations helping
out and we're going to carry on so if
the message from this is one thing it's
we're not going anywhere Mr Putin we're
here for the Long Haul we're standing by
Ukraine you need to recalculate you need
to make a change you need to leave
Ukraine return it to Sovereign borders
and uphold the international law that
you say you respect thank you